[Musique]
le mois d'avril et le mois de l'autisme
une condition qui gagne à être connu
encore aujourd'hui la science n'a pas
percé tous ses mystères et ce flou
laisse parfois le champ libre à la
désinformation
c'est ce qu'a constaté valérie des
roches depuis qu'elle a reçu il ya
quelques années un diagnostic de
syndrome d'asperger r une des facettes
des troubles du spectre autistique
valérie des roches merci de nous
accueillir pourtant l'aide de tous ces
mythes qui circulent sur l'autisme
oui en tant que personnes autistes temps
voit beaucoup circulé oui internet les
réseaux sociaux à quoi ça ressemble mais
on a par exemple que l'eau de javel
pourrait guérir et l'autisme bien donner
à ses enfants thé ça peut vraiment aller
très très loin
beaucoup de mythes vraiment qui parle
qu'on peut guérir donc beaucoup
l'éducation en france quand j'avais 28
ans je suis arrivé avec mon ancienne
famille et moi dit je suis à prades et
demi avec ton diagnostic valérie puis a
vraiment dit mme montas mots parce que
ces gens là ne foutent rien dans la vie
et que moi j'ai une maîtrise donc je
peux pas être autiste un médecin qui m'a
dit ça j'ai été vraiment choqués qu'ils
connaissent pas le syndrome d'asperger
c'est lourd quand même que sont les
pistes de solution valérie je crois
vraiment que les gens devraient nous
inclure dans les décisions prises par
rapport aux autres c'est sûr que ça soit
les spécialistes ou le gouvernement
parce que c'est vraiment nous les mieux
placés pour des caisses qui se passe à
l'intérieur de nous faut donner une
chance aux gens parce que souvent un
coup qu'on va nous connaître
c'est ce qu'on devrait apprécier on a vu
des humoristes à la télé qui ont avoué
qu'ils avaient le syndrome asperger donc
l'oit et ouais si ça depuis que j'ai
fait ma sortie publique depuis que j'ai
dit aux gens je suis atteint d'un
syndrome d'asperger
la réaction que j'ai le plus souvent
c'est les gens qui en ont vraiment
besoin
lui ça devrait continuer parce que c'est
des exemples qui montrent que l'autisme
y en ait vraiment de toutes les couleurs
on n'est pas des extraterrestres est
vraiment intéressant et la borde le fait
que des personnes comme toi donc public
des personnages publics sortent au grand
jour pour dire affirmé don kelly lequel
quelle est leur condition tu vois à quel
point ça peut aider plusieurs personnes
ça inspire déjà ben moi je le sais parce
que je reçois beaucoup de messages puis
je vois des gens après mes spectacles
puis je suis chanceux intégrer les
dommages collatéraux moi j'ai des
avantages collatéraux le g20 comme égal
depuis ça va être là bas oui à tout le
monde en parle
il s'est encore les gens visionnaires
casse cette entrevue le aujourd'hui que
quand je lis eu je suis sorti du bureau
du médecin et j'avais juste envie de le
dire à n'importe qui ça et rural crier
supposée comme ça ici je le sais je
comprends maintenant je le sais c'est
pour ça que j'avais le goût de le dire
le fait de prendre la parole
publiquement ça aussi c'est une arme
contre la désinformation quand une
personne comme toi le fait est ce que tu
constates mois dans les médias bunge
expose une de ses facettes là je suis
pas leurs représentants des autistes
mais par contre je sais qu'il ya une
partie des gens qui se reconnaissent
beaucoup en moi ils connectent fond
comme c'est incroyable ce que tu me dis
mon show comme moi ok c'est si sa taille
tant mieux mais je suis comme je suis
plié des gens qui font comme si
exactement je souffre comme toi je pense
qu'il ya 10 ou 15 ans une fausse
nouvelle sur l'autisme
ça passe un peu dans le beurre sur
internet mais aujourd'hui les vues que
les gens ont tous dans leur entourage
quelqu'un qui a été diagnostiquée où ils
en ont entendu parler à l'école parce
que tous les enfants sont rendues
autistes que ça crée un climat plus
propice aux fausses nouvelles
malheureusement mais en même temps les
médias s'intéressent plus aussi à
combattre ces fausses nouvelles lectures
on va gagner on va pas tellement on va
gagner quand même combat